hello I am here tonight to honor my
wonderful friend and this is a very easy
yes for me because none of the many
talents and traits that they asked me to
say about this wonderful friend are lies
and I stand behind every one of them
with enthusiasm and wholeheartedness so
this friend she is one of the great
comedians of our time delighting us with
her performances on Saturday Night Live
and Parks and Recreation that's true she
is a prolific producer and with her
company paper kite she has brought us
comedy gems like difficult people and
broad city that's true she's co-founded
the upright citizens brigade which is
one of our most influential improv
theaters of our generation true she's
won an Emmy and a Golden Globe that is
true she is committed to empowering
young women with her website spark
growth as a party that is true she wrote
a memoir that was a New York Times
bestseller called yes please true she
will delight us once again soon starring
opposite Will Ferrell in a new comedy
called the house coming to a theater
near you true she speaks seven languages
fluently she can also speak all of them
in pig latin true she calls me every
morning to wake me up with a beautiful
Irish folk song I don't even have to set
my alarm because I know she's gonna call
that's true
she restores French impressionist
paintings for the Louvre in her free
time that's true she couldn't be here
tonight because she's busy working on
climate change
she just replaced the US and the Paris
Accord
oh wait that's actually not true because
she's here tonight that one's not true
sorry most of these might seem like an
exaggeration but I'm trying to punctuate
a point which is that my friends warmth
and her authenticity and her death
debility to make us laugh in the least
obvious way is truly inspiring to me and
to many many others so she may not sing
me awake every morning but it really
really feels
she does whoever's 2017 inspiration
award goes to Amy Poehler oh thank you
Rashida I love you
you're beautiful smooth-coated sea otter
Rashida you are his wide of heart as you
are spin of wrist and I'm very proud of
how we celebrated the strengths of
female relationships on Parks and
Recreation yes here here and I like to
think that our characters of Leslie and
Anne would spend their last days
together in some kind of polyamorous
situation that benefits both of them
financially this is the last speech of
the night and there's so many many
people in this room so many broads who I
appreciate and read and watch all the
time Sharon Catlin French and Saunders
little mix you know I remember going to
the club's back in the 90s and watching
Little Mix do improv and I was like guys
about thank you very much to Glamour for
this award thank you Joe for letting me
sit at your right hand
it does feel silly to accept this award
this year
but in the US this year is all about
undeserved wins so yeah
so let me just say I'm the most
glamorous I'm the most beautiful this
win is huge nobody respects glamorous
women like I do
okay there's so many tens in the room
tonight
your mayor says there's no reason to be
alarmed you should be alarmed with rim
gunfire I don't know I don't know um
I've done very little this year on
purpose I've hid it's been a nightmare
this year um but I spent the beginning
of this year just a rage crying and
eating and yelling at the man who took
my parking space and my eye doctor and
just getting into fights with directors
on email um but now things are turning
can you feel it
no but bad things are happening all over
the UK has had a tough you know couple
of weeks but everyone's fine London is
fine you don't need to pray for them
London is fine there's elections coming
up and I wanted to get better acquainted
with the intricacies of what each party
supported but I asked a friend of mine
from Newcastle to explain to me and I
couldn't understand what he was saying
I'm sorry I don't have a tape maybe one
suggestion though maybe change the
Labour Party to the scheduled c-section
party uh-huh I feel like more people
would join it if they knew it was easier
and they could pick today but I am so
happy to be celebrating tonight among
all of you fantastic women because
turning to women is what I've been doing
all year yes lady in the back is like
hahaha yes but I have been I have
actually been going to women to say what
what do I do
how are you doing it I've been asking
them for support and I've been trying to
be a witness for them and I think that's
how we get through by being there for
each other and hopefully laughing in the
face of fear and despair and if you
don't believe me listen to your local
studs William and Harry it's alright to
cry now Britain they've told you you
should feel your feelings so replace
your stiff upper lip with a soft lower
tremble my dear friend the Dalai Lama
once said
genuine compassion is a source of
genuine human happiness and Kendrick
Lamar once said be humble [ __ ] holla
sit down I think both apply so as your
inspiration award I would like to
inspire you all to do what I'm trying to
do which is to support funny and fierce
women everywhere in my home in my life
in my work we have so many stories to
tell women of color gay women Muslim
women trans women Jewish women unlikable
women the illusive woman over 45 very
hard to photograph in her natural
habitat
what is he she hunts at night but I
refuse to have a cruel summer I want to
look forward I'm tired of being tired
angry and defeated and so I will gather
strength from this award to do what I
can do to support the women here and try
to be a voice for all the women who are
not invited into this room
this is for all the witches thank you
[Applause]